it's fine do you think he notices yeah
Tristan Thompson makes his first
appearance on Keeping Up with the
Kardashians
since daughter trues birth and it was
blurry you may not recognize him but it
is in fact Coco's ex fans went crazy on
social media asking why his face was
blurred out in all of the couple's
family photos and that video album gonna
figure it all out I promise you Chloe
addressed the obvious on Twitter saying
she didn't even notice that was the case
tweeting in part he might not have
signed a waiver to show those images why
would I want to blur his face I'm not
hiding his identity lol are you still in
love I am in love I know I love him but
still I'm not gonna act like nothing's
wrong Chloe and her bestie Malika jetted
off to Cleveland with true in tow on
Sunday night's episode and things got
deep Mallika checked in on her besties
well-being and current relationship
status she counts it's been seven months
and there's only so it's been seven
months yeah I'm allowed to do things
when I want to do it but he also needs
to know you're one stupid weekend or
whatever you did look what it did to you
know three years of a relationship you
just demolished it by that so was that
worth it for you
he knows I'm still trying I don't have
to come here I'm not here to play games
although things are kosher now keeping
up address the Jordan wood scandal in a
recent teaser for the rest of the season
this is going to change that their
relationship
for you and Jordan it's like a divorce
she does
you